[Music]
here a visual politic we're not exactly
massive fans of Donald Trump and viewers
of our spanish-language channel we'll
know particularly however there is one
area where we must admit that Donald
Trump is absolutely correct
if you want to be a citizen of Mexico
you and let's assume you're a person
aversion okay you want to be if you
could not become a citizen of Mexico
it's the hardest place just about in the
country in the world to become a citizen
it's like in this case Donald Trump is
telling the truth Mexico has an
immigration policy that is way more
restrictive than the American one you
understand this better in 2015 the
Mexican government kicked out of its
country 100,000 foreigners while its
neighbor to the north kicked out 300,000
okay so actually on the face of things
that looks as if the u.s. supports more
people than Mexico right I mean 300,000
versus 100,000 but you really must think
about this in relative term for one
Mexico's population is three times
smaller than the United States and it's
also a far less attractive destination
for immigrants
dad said we can say that the Mexican
authorities support nearly everyone who
crosses into the country through their
southern border with saline and
Guatemala that is they deport all of the
people who decide to stay in Mexico
rather than heading further north to the
United States in fact while America has
an immigrant population of 14% which is
by the way average in terms of developed
countries Mexico has an immigrant
population of just 1% in fact while the
Mexican president Enrique Pena Nieto
always saying this to Donald Trump los
mexicanos en estados unidos so gente
enesta Americans living in u.s. our
honor hard-working people they are good
people they respect family they respect
their communities and they deserve
respect
como tal los mexicanos medicine el
respeto
de todos 48 percent of the Mexican
population holds a negative or very
negative opinion about immigrants from
Central America in fact in 2016 a
Mexican newspaper called la manana
published the following
[Music]
yes to the border wall but in the south
of Mexico the problems between the US
and Mexico can be solved by building a
border like the one proposed by Donald
Trump but in the south so we can keep
illegal aliens out of Central America
it's so rather interesting right and
that's why in today's visual politic
video we're going to be looking in to
Mexico's immigration policy why does
mexico deport Central American
immigrants the first thing that we need
to understand before talking about
immigration to Mexico is their
geographical location let's imagine that
you live in Nicaragua and you want to
move to the United States let's also say
that you have no money to purchase a
plane ticket in this case the only way
for you to get from Nicaragua to the
United States is by land and that means
going through Mexico currently the
biggest flow of immigrants in the world
is from Central America to the United
States of America
in 2015 alone over 22 million people
made this trip it's an extremely
dangerous journey on roads that are in
terrible condition and immigrants also
passed through some incredibly violent
areas and don't forget Mexican states
like chapathi Aereo in Sinaloa the
hotspot for drug trafficking welcome to
las olas procedures these are for all
kinds of abuses acquis extortion mapping
for human trafficking drug trafficking
human and sexual slavery personal
relationships life
do you understand this better when some
of the immigrants arrive in the south of
Mexico they have to continue their
journey to the US on the roof of a train
this train has become known as the Beast
or the death train and it's not hard to
figure out why with an ejaculation why
some immigrants inside to see Mexico
this situation was the perfect excuse
for the Mexican government to pass
Veerle to pop the ser or population law
this was passed in the mid-1970s the law
was poly put into place in order to
restrict the flow of immigrants to the
country in order to avoid human
trafficking and abuse so this sounds
like a well intentioned law so what
exactly was the problem here well what
it first appeared to be something good
for foreigners it quickly became hell
for them and now you may be wondering
what exactly made this law quite so bad
for immigrant well quite simply it gave
the government the power to expel
foreigners for reasons as ludicrous as
this one
[Music]
the secretary can deny foreigners and
comes to the country or change the
quality or characteristics of the
migration in order to keep a demographic
balance in otherwise Mexico only wants
immigrants from wealthy countries and if
possible it's better if that skin is
white and well what's the result of all
this well it turns out that seven out of
every ten immigrants to Mexico are from
the United States and what about the
rest of them what about that other three
well they're mostly from Spain in fact
Mexican have twice as many Spaniards
living in it as it does Guatemala now
this wouldn't exactly be a big surprise
except for the fact that Guatemala
shares a border with Mexico and Spain is
thousands of miles away across an ocean
but this is not all Mexico has an equal
number of German immigrants as it does
Peruvian so if you come from Europe or
the United States you're going to have
no problem getting a visa for Mexico
apparently you're helping to improve
that a demographic balance but if you
happen to be from Peru and want to live
in the country of Robert Rodriguez well
good luck to the Mexican government you
are nothing more than a demographic
[Music]
but hold on for a second because there's
more according to the
previously-mentioned law being an
immigrant in Mexico is a felony this
means that at any moment federal agents
can request your documentation and if
you don't have that documentation you
can be forced to leave the country and
pay a fine of two months average salary
in Mexico okay okay so now you might be
thinking well every country gets to
determine its own immigration policy
right well that's absolutely right and
until 2010 and no other government
complained about Mexico's immigration
policy in 2010 something happened that
embarrassed the entire nation Arizona
Governor Jan Brewer on Friday signs of
state immigration bill into law it is
considered to be among the toughest
legislation in the nation as ironic as
it sounds Arizona law which was meant to
stop immigrants from Mexico was a copy
of that same Mexican law but it's
actually in practice it was slightly
less extreme
for example while Arizona's government
considers it to be a felony to be an
illegal immigrant it doesn't really
matter because Arizona's state law
doesn't apply to the federal government
so the reality was the federal police
could do nothing nevertheless this law
caught the attention of the world's
media and the president back then
Felipe Calderon didn't remain silent so
that regulation gets a century in
criminal every regulation that
criminalizes immigration a social
phenomenon and economic phenomena every
law that penalizes it is an opening at
the door for intolerance hate and
discrimination abuse will aplicación de
la ley and well there you have it
since that day dictionaries next the
word hypocrisy has started including a
picture of Felipe Calderon and quickly
following the statement came the world's
reaction the Mexican government's were
forced to change their population law
that we mentioned this meant that
immigration to Mexico was no longer a
felony plus deal with on that for just
one second because that is not the end
of our story
yes it is true that Mexico changed its
immigration law but it didn't do so in
time remember when I said that the
Mexican Federal Police can request
documentation of any person at any time
well that is still happening today today
in the United States the authorities
need to suspect you of committing a
crime if they want to ask you the
documentation this means it's not very
easy for them to stop you on the street
and arrest you for being than being
eliminated meanwhile down in Mexico this
is happening every single day add to
this the limited control of the country
having with our own police force and you
get stories like this one to escape the
potassium migrants often pay bribes
through i'mmm agents of between 30 and
300 dollars and of course the mass
deportations of Central American
immigrants remain exactly the same but
do you really think the Mexico is the
only place where this is happening
because the answer is absolutely not now
normally when we talk about immigration
we're normally talking about people who
are living in a poor country moving to a
rich country
[Music]
the truth is in 2015 over 18 million
people moved from one poor country to
another poor country they were just
moving to a poor country that is
slightly better off than their original
country as an example every year
thousands of people move from Bangladesh
to India and the authorities don't
exactly welcome them with open arms just
consider what Narendra Modi said the
Indian president when he was running for
office
[Music]
you can write it down after May 16th
these Vama Veche is better be prepared
with their backs back this is really a
big difference when compared to the
immigrant friendly policies of countries
like Canada or New Zealand which by the
way are some of the wealthiest countries
in the world
[Music]
but this is just our opinion here and
visual politic and we would love to know
what you think do you think that Europe
and the United States should follow
example set by countries like Mexico and
India or follow the examples of
countries like Canada and New Zealand
let us know in the comment section below
this video we'd love to know what you
think also if you enjoyed this video
please do click that like button below
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday and off the you next time
you
[Music]